Last night the Iranians struck the home
of Benjamin Netanyahu. I looked it up as
soon as you said it.
>> [laughter]
>> The BBC is reporting it as Ben Gvir was
in a car accident last night. I mean I
mean I won't be surprised. I won't be
surprised. You know, they probably would
say, you know, he he fell over and died.
I want to invite you to add [music]
something powerful to your Sadaqah
Jariyah list. We're on a mission
>> to teach tens of thousands of people
around the world
>> how to pray salah properly.
>> Just imagine this.
>> You help someone learn with you how to
pray. How to recite Surah Al-Fatiha.
Every Fajr, Zuhr, Asr, Maghrib,
>> Isha, Tahajjud,
>> Tarawih. Every prayer for the rest of
their lives, you share in a reward.
>> When they [music] teach their children,
and their children's children,
the reward continues for you.
>> For just 100 pounds, you can help teach
20 to 60 people
>> like me learn salah. Donate today and
earn rewards that never stop.
As-salamu alaykum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh, brothers and sisters and
dear friends. Hope you guys are doing
well, inshallah. So, there are rumors
that Ben Gvir, the dirtbag, the scumbag,
I think defense minister, whatever
minister he is, the dirtbag minister, he
is for that matter,
has been reportedly missing, wounded, or
killed.
Here we're going to go to a video of
some American officials who are claiming
that that's the case. And not only that,
there is rumors that Benjamin
Netanyahu's brother has been killed by
the Iranian missile
strikes. Let's watch for ourselves
inshallah subhanahu wa ta'ala and see if
this good news is true.
You know, the Iranians are showing an
ability to
get intelligence information inputs in
the morning and strike in the afternoon
with deadly effect.
And also, they're starting to expand
their target deck. And there is rumors
that they are getting that intelligence
from China and Russia. China sent some
planes there, which I'll play the video
in a minute, in sha'allah, um that went
off radar. And it's room There's rumors
that China understands that if Iran goes
down, it can affect them geopolitically.
So, that's why they are giving them
intelligence, and there planes that, you
know, war warfare uh planes,
subhanallah, have been heading towards
Iran. So, that's the reason why we're
getting the strategic locations to where
to hit specifically. They didn't uh
invent the concept of regime change.
That was Israel on day one, killing Ali
Khamenei. Last night, the Iranians
struck the home of Benjamin Netanyahu.
They killed his brother.
They struck the home of uh Ben Gvir. Uh
he's he's seriously wounded, may not
survive. Uh Iran is going to start to
take out the totality of Israel's
leadership. Um this is the the reality
of this conflict. Israel played the
regime change game. It's going to be the
Israelis that are going to be paying um
the highest price. The Iranians are no
longer wearing kid gloves. They've taken
them off, and they're coming in bare
knuckle. Yes, and their new uh
um religious leader
um has announced that is no peace. He
said he's going to let the missiles
talk. And so, you can see very Iran is
taking this matter very seriously, and
so far they are winning this war. You
can see that so far they are actually
winning this war, subhanallah. They're
reporting it. This is interesting. I
looked it up as soon as you said it.
>> [laughter]
>> The BBC is reporting it as Ben Gvir was
in a car accident last night. I mean I
won't I won't be surprised. I won't be
surprised. Uh you know, they probably
would say, you know, he uh he fell over
and died. You know, um we know who's
behind the BBC, as well.
Does that surprise you?
Uh you know, they can report it any the
way any way they want. We know that his
home is on fire. Um so, maybe he crashed
his car near his house. Um
>> [laughter]
>> Don't you find funny how the Americans
have just so woken up? They did They
even making jokes about this now. Like,
they just do not give a damn about
Israel's Israel's. They understand what
they are doing to their children in
those Epstein Islands, and then waiting
for the children to grow up, after
they've raped them, these pedophile
Satanists, and then send them to the war
so they can die for them, for their
greater Israel plan. That's interesting.
It just I mean, the only reason I just
can't help but be amused by this cuz it
would not surprise me for the BBC to
provide cover for a story like this. So,
yeah,
You and I now know that the BBC
reporters that work overseas are vetted
by MI6 before they're allowed to take on
their assignments. There you go. He just
put it really well. There you go. It's
vetted by the MI6 and MI5 before
it actually is aired. Subhanallah. And
not only that, now, what's happening in
Israel is the officials the the
officials are taking down CCTV cameras.
Here's a Here's a little glimpse for you
guys. Ben-Gvir's house is on fire.
Benjamin Netanyahu's brother is soon to
be killed. And what are they doing? They
are breaking CCTV cameras so they are
not used as evidence to show the
destruction. Watch this for yourself.
That is unbelievable. The IDF is
literally going to houses, homes, and
taking down CCTV cameras. And they are
sentencing people to 5 years
so they don't see the reality of what is
going on in Israel. That's not going to
help you because you can take all
cameras down. Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala is
all watching. Subhanallah, he sees. And
Allah says, "Do you not ever think Allah
is unaware of what the evil doers are
doing? He only delays them for a day
their eyes will stare in horror." Take
down the CCTV cameras. Take it all down.
The whole world knows this is the
beginning of the end of Israel because
America's woken up. The whole world is
waking up to how evil and satanic you
guys are. And subhanallah, may Allah
expose them further. Here is what the
Iranian military had to say about the
amount of ammunition they have and what
they've just sent. Let's watch it cuz it
is quite horrifying for the Israelis.
So there you go, brothers and sisters.
You saw for yourself. The Iranian
military are saying that they are ready
for a prolonged war. The idea of her
taking CCTV cameras down. American
officials are saying that Ben-Gvir's
house is on fire. Ben and Jerry's
brother is dead. This does not look good
for Israel or America at all. I will
keep you guys more updated, inshallah,
brothers and sisters, with more news of
the Iran
war, Iran-Israel-American war.
Subhanallah, well, they started. Uh so
subscribe to the channel inshallah and
share this video. As-salamu alaykum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.